[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas si los hablamos
de espionaje de espías de verdad no del
agente 007 es más que probable que
rápidamente se os venga a la cabeza las
operaciones del mossad guía o también de
los poderosos servicios de inteligencia
de rusia o incluso del gigante chino de
hecho a día de hoy aún sigue sin
resultar extraño toparnos con noticias
como estas
eeuu cierra el consulado chino en
houston por un aumento de los casos de
espionaje chino noruega arresta un
hombre sospechoso de espiar para rusia
en el mundo de la inteligencia no solo
forma parte del cine o la literatura
sigue siendo un pilar fundamental en las
políticas de seguridad e influencia de
muchos países luchar contra el
terrorismo vigilar al adversario y
también a los amigos buscar secretos
castigar a tu enemigo o entrometerse en
las entrañas políticas de un país hostil
para poder llegar a desestabilizarlo son
tan solo algunas de las operaciones más
comunes de una actividad que se lleva a
cabo en un mundo muy distinto al que
conocemos un mundo de sombras recelos y
desconfianza un mundo donde no siempre
el estado de derecho actúa como un
límite eficaz hay que decir por supuesto
del peligro que puede llegar a suponer
el espionaje llevado a cabo por países
sin límites países en los que los
derechos humanos la democracia y la
libertad brillan por su ausencia pero
hasta qué punto este tipo de actividades
suponen un riesgo para las democracias
la libertad y la estabilidad
internacional a qué riesgos nos
enfrentamos exactamente queridos amigos
para responder a estas preguntas en este
vídeo nos toca desplazarnos hasta la
península
fijaos
si tuviéramos que poneros el ejemplo de
un país que hasta hoy ha vivido sumido
en una guerra de espionaje constante ese
país no sería otro que corea del sur
como sabéis la península de corea es el
último lugar de todo el planeta donde la
guerra fría no solo nunca termino sino
que hoy sigue tan viva como en cualquier
otro periodo de tiempo las incursiones
de espías surcoreanos en corea del norte
y con mucha más frecuencia la de espías
norcoreanos en corea del sur ha sido una
constante durante décadas digamos que
desde que se firmó el armisticio de la
guerra de corea de 1953 en materia de
espionaje estos dos países no se han
dado tregua por supuesto de los dos el
país que más daños ha provocado con
mucha diferencia ha sido corea del norte
un país que no solo ha infiltrado espías
sino también unidades de élite
entrenadas para realizar atentados en el
sur
[Música]
qué me decís os apetece saber más sobre
la que probablemente es la parte más
oscura de la convivencia de dos estados
ideológicamente opuestos como son las
dos coreas pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
el espionaje método de supervivencia
para los 15 amigos amigas de visual
polític para entender mejor lo que vamos
a contar más adelante antes tenemos que
echar la vista atrás y ver dónde empezó
todo tras librarse de la ocupación
japonesa en la península de corea se
dividió en dos mitades en 1948 una mitad
bajo un gobierno comunista afín a la
unión soviética y otra bajo un gobierno
conservador afín a los eeuu y occidente
sin embargo ahí no iba a quedar todo las
tensiones entre ambos regímenes
terminaron con la invasión norcoreana
del sur en 1950 una invasión que provocó
una guerra que ya no se detuvo hasta el
53 cuando se acordó un alto el fuego un
armisticio que sigue en vigor hoy en día
sin embargo lejos de llegar la paz y la
tranquilidad las décadas posteriores han
estado plagados de producciones ataques
espionajes y atentados unas acciones
dirigidas fundamentalmente a
desestabilizar a la otra parte unas
acciones que corea del norte ha sabido
llevar al límite
digamos que los kim han convertido a sus
servicios de inteligencia en su punta de
lanza en el mundo ya sea para intimidar
a sus enemigos ganar fuerza en la mesa
de negociación robar secretos
industriales castigar a posibles
opositores o incluso buscar vías con las
de saltarse las sanciones
internacionales los servicios secretos
norcoreanos juegan un papel clave
esencial en la supervivencia de la
dictadura comunista
los espías son tan importantes para el
régimen que el gobierno norcoreano
considera sus espías como los
funcionarios de más alto rango para que
os hagáis una idea están al nivel de los
propios generales del mismísimo ejército
popular de corea que es como se conoce a
las fuerzas armadas de este país de esta
forma a los espías tienen muchos
privilegios como por ejemplo salarios
muy elevados acceso a la educación
superior o la capacidad para viajar al
extranjero lo que por supuesto no es
nada común en uno de los países más
cerrados y aislados del mundo
ahora bien puede que os estáis
preguntando pero alberto de qué estamos
hablando exactamente hasta dónde llegan
estas operaciones qué papel juega
realmente el espionaje
queréis detalles y ejemplos concretos
bien atentos
una historia de provocaciones si existe
una obsesión entre los gerifaltes del
régimen norcoreano y esa no es otra que
hacerle la vida imposible a sus vecinos
del sur de esta forma mientras que el
tipo de espionaje realizado por corea
del sur ha estado sobre todo encaminado
a recabar información militar y sobre
los planes futuros del país
el espionaje norcoreano ha sido muy
diferente evidentemente en este vídeo
nos vamos a poder hablar de todas y cada
una de las operaciones conocidas que han
llevado a cabo que son muchísimas pero
sí que os vamos a contar algunas de las
más llamativas y amigos para conocer la
primera de ellas tenemos que viajar
hasta los años 60 en este momento en el
sur gobernaba el presidente
y ascendió al poder tras un golpe de
estado este hombre que por cierto es
padre de la expresidenta ahora
encarcelada para túnez era un militar
profundamente conservador y anti
comunista como os podéis imaginar
hablamos de un personaje que no le caía
muy bien al dictador norcoreano kim
il-sung el abuelo del actual líder su
línea dura contra corea del norte su
persecución a todo lo que oliera a
izquierdas y el aperturismo diplomático
y comercial que puso en marcha y que
situó por primera vez a cora del sur en
el mapa internacional fueron motivos más
que suficientes para ponerle
literalmente en la diana al menos dos
fueron los intentos de corea del norte
que asesinar a parte
el primer intento se produjo en enero de
1968 31 soldados de una unidad de élite
del ejército popular de corea se
infiltraron en corea del sur llegando
hasta la mismísima casa azul la
residencia del presidente surcoreano en
seúl
el comando norcoreano penetro la capital
sin demasiadas dificultades y
consiguieron pasar prácticamente
desapercibidos y aproximarse a tan sólo
100 metros de la casa un momento en el
que los equipos de seguridad que
protegían el presidente surcoreano
descubrieron las operaciones se produjo
entonces un tiroteo entre el comando
norcoreano y los soldados y la policía
del sur un tiroteo que acabó con la vida
de parte del comando y de decenas de
surcoreanos todo a escasos 100 metros
del dormitorio del presidente finalmente
el asalto terminó con la captura de uno
de los integrantes de la operación el
resto de los que habían sobrevivido al
tiroteo tomaron veneno para quitarse de
en medio y así evitar ser interrogados
y si lo habéis escuchado bien de locos a
los espías norcoreanos les entrenan en
doctrinas siempre y llanamente para
quitarse la vida antes de ser obligados
a revelar cualquier tipo de información
al enemigo
evidentemente en terrible decisión
influye lo que pueda ocurrirle a sus
propias familias como seguramente nos
podemos imaginar en cuerda del norte la
vida que puede tener la familia de un
héroe caído no es ni mucho menos la
misma que la de alguien considerado un
traidor o un desertor
[Música]
pero bien no nos desviemos el segundo
intento de asesinato contra park se
produjo apenas cinco años más tarde en
el 74 en el teatro nacional de corea
durante la celebración del día de la
liberación de la ocupación japonesa
curiosamente fue un infiltrado
norcoreano nacido en japón llamado mundo
one que disparó al presidente desde el
público sin embargo no le dio a él no
sino a su mujer la primera dama que
falleció poco después pero si todo esto
os parece de película
bueno pues os digo que ni siquiera
habéis visto el tráiler esperada que os
contemos lo que hicieron los norcoreanos
en el 87 un año antes de celebrarse los
juegos olímpicos de seúl
resulta que al dictador norcoreano kim
il-sung no le hacía ninguna pero que
ninguna gracia que corea de sur
albergará los juegos olímpicos de 1988 y
es que claro durante ese año en su sería
uno de los protagonistas de la
actualidad internacional un escaparate
perfecto para que los ojos del mundo
pudiesen ver el enorme desarrollo que
estaba experimentando el país por eso la
primera medida que tomó el líder
norcoreano fue anunciar que en 1989 se
celebrarían en corea del norte una
especie de juegos olímpicos socialistas
paralelos el llamado festival mundial de
la juventud y los estudiantes un evento
que costó 4.000 millones de dólares y
para cuya celebración el regimiento
tiene construyó un gigantesco estadio
olímpico de 200 millones el famoso
estadio make gay el estadio más grande
del mundo
[Música]
ojo no olvidéis que ya en ese momento
corea del norte era un país muy pobre no
aparece desde luego la mejor decisión
del mundo gastarse unos recursos que no
tienes en organizar unos juegos
olímpicos socialistas mientras su gente
pasa hambre en fin cosas de dictadores
pero desgraciadamente los norcoreanos no
se quedaron ahí lo peor fue el maléfico
plan para reventar los juegos de seúl un
plan que tuvo como objetivo meterle
miedo al mundo y crear el sentimiento la
idea de que ir a seúl a los juegos
olímpicos no era algo nada seguro así
que qué mejor que derribar un avión de
korean air lleno de pasajeros en fin y
no nos estamos tomando el pelo de hecho
eso fue precisamente lo que hicieron
en 1987 meses antes de los juegos
olímpicos del 88 dos espías norcoreanos
se embarcaron en el vuelo 858 / pack
taki saúl con escala en abu dhabi
bangkok dos espías se bajaron del avión
en la escala de abu dhabi dejando una
bomba con temporizador en el interior
poco después el avión explotó matando a
115 personas durante la huida de los dos
espías 15000 un hombre de 70 años y kim
jong y una mujer de 26 fueron apresados
por su parte kim sunil consiguió ingerir
el veneno que siempre llevan los espías
norcoreanos en sus misiones pero kim
jong-il no lo logró y fue llevado a seúl
junhui viajaba con un pasaporte japonés
haciéndose pasar por japonesa gracias a
las clases de idioma y modales que le
habían dado en corea del norte una
japonesa secuestrada esta ha sido por
cierto otra de las actividades favoritas
de corea del norte durante décadas
secuestran a gente de otros países
especialmente a japoneses y surcoreanos
el caso es que kim jong-il fue condenada
a muerte pero consiguió un perdón
presidencial lógicamente esta mujer era
una valiosísima fuente de información
para los servicios surcoreanos así que
claro valía más viva que muerta no
obstante sus muestras de arrepentimiento
le valieron recibir la nacionalidad
surcoreana e incluso el perdón de los
familiares de las víctimas actualmente
esta ex espía tiene 58 años y vive en un
lugar secreto de corea del sur secreto
por temor a ser asesinada por agentes
norcoreanos y ha ofrecido varias
entrevistas en las que ha dicho cosas
como estas cuando confesé y lo hice a
regañadientes pensé en que mi familia
podría estar en peligro en corea del
norte fue una difícil decisión pero
empecé a darme cuenta de que era lo
correcto para las víctimas para que
pudieran saber la verdad no hay otro
país como corea del norte el país entero
está pensado para mostrar lealtad a la
familia real que es como una religión no
hay derechos humanos no hay libertades
cuando conocí a las familias de las
víctimas estuvimos todos llorando y
abrazando los kim jong y ex espía
norcoreano pero ojo porque esto de dejar
vivir
a los espías y garantizar su seguridad
para obtener información no es la única
medida de protección que ha desarrollado
el sur de hecho no es ni siquiera la más
importante la principal es la ley de
seguridad nacional antiguamente llamada
ley anti comunista
[Música]
esta ley regula absolutamente todo
acerca de los contactos con el vecino
del norte por ejemplo si un surcoreano
quiere viajar a corea del norte esta ley
establece que el viaje solo puede
producirse de mediar un motivo muy
justificado y debe ser aprobado por el
gobierno esta ley también prohíbe todos
los libros norcoreanos o los que
ensalzan al régimen o al comunismo del
mismo modo que sirve como paraguas legal
para perseguir y bloquear webs
norcoreanas o a favor de pyongyang con
esta ley lo que se pretende es
básicamente eliminar cualquier contenido
ideológico que el régimen norcoreano
pudiera usar para extender su influencia
del sur la pregunta es de un gobierno
limitar el acceso a sus ciudadanos a
determinados contenidos aunque sean
apología del totalitarismo no es una
cuestión menor así que si os parece
abrimos debate abajo
en los comentarios pero bien llegamos
hasta aquí y seguro que algunos estaréis
pensando vale vale alberto pero a ver
estos casos que nos has contado son
sucesos que ocurrieron hace más de tres
décadas hace mucho tiempo pero y ahora y
en la actualidad sigue habiendo espías
norcoreanos en el sur
pues la respuesta es que si nunca ha
dejado de haberlos y aunque el número de
comandos operativos es indeterminado por
supuesto se cree que se cuentan por
cientos recaban información atemorizan a
funcionarios y políticos surcoreanos
roban diseños industriales y buscan
formas de saltarse las sanciones
internacionales pero sin duda el tipo de
espionaje que más tirón tiene ahora para
los norcoreanos no es este tipo de
espionaje llamamos le tradicional de
agentes infiltrados sino el que se hace
en la red en internet el ciber espionaje
de hecho corea del norte ha pasado en
pocos años de hacer chapuceros ataques
informáticos a ser un país muy tímido en
el mundo de la ciberseguridad algo de lo
que en cierto modo ya os hemos hablado
aquí en visual político pero os apetece
saber un poco más sobre este nuevo campo
de batalla pues vamos allá
el mío espionaje
cuando se trata de hacer el mal toda
innovación es poca verdad os acordáis de
las técnicas de la inés ya que vivimos
en un pasado vídeo si no lo habéis visto
os lo dejo abajo en la descripción el
caso es que esto mismo lo de que para
hacer mal toda innovación es poca es
exactamente lo que parecen haber pensado
en corea del norte uno de los países más
pobres y atrasados tecnológicamente de
todo el mundo que sin embargo tiene a
todo un escuadrón de élite de hackers
informáticos
hablamos del grupo apt 37 como un
ejército de alrededor de 6000 hackers
que se dedican fundamentalmente a tres
cosas realizar ataques informáticos
contra países enemigos al espionaje
industrial sobre todo de la industria
militar y por último a la creación y
dispersión del virus que roban o estafa
en dinero el más sonado de esto último
fue precisamente el wanna cry un virus
que en 2017 atacó inutilizó alrededor de
300.000 ordenadores en todo el mundo
y no sólo eso como ya os contamos corea
del norte también ha utilizado su
ejército de ciber soldados para robar 81
millones de dólares de un banco de
bangladesh o para destruir los
servidores de sony pictures como
respuesta a la película de interview en
la cual se producía el asesinato de kim
jong-un pero no tenemos que irnos para
atrás en el tiempo ni mucho menos
atentos a este titular agosto de 2020
corea del norte- fibra ataque israelí
roba datos clasificados que podrían ser
vendidos a irán si así es como quien
dice prácticamente antes de ayer se
confirmó que los hackers norcoreanos
habían conseguido vencer las ciber
defensas del ejército israelí uno de los
cuerpos tecnológicamente más preparados
de todo el mundo este ataque que más
bien deberíamos llamarle ciber espionaje
industrial se centró en robar datos de
modelos de armamento que no se sabe bien
a dónde irán a parar además de para el
consumo propio no podemos olvidar que
irán el archienemigo de israel es aliado
de cora del norte y podrían haber
recurrido el grupo apt 37 norcoreano
para servirse una dulce venganza
[Música]
el caso es que si en su dimensión física
el ejército norcoreano no parece que
esté preparado para atacar a otros
países o hacer misiones en el extranjero
porque no formarse un buen equipo de
hackers y hacerlo por internet el
teletrabajo llega a cora del norte
la jugada aparece maestra además pueden
utilizar esta vía para robar información
a las empresas por ejemplo patentes y
poder producir sus propias copias pero
dios hasta aquí turno para ti creéis que
corea del sur debería haber respondido
militarmente a las numerosas incursiones
de espías y agentes especiales
norcoreanos está el mundo a salvo de la
naciente superpotencia ciber militar
norcoreana como siempre nuestras las
preguntas vuestras las respuestas es ha
gustado este vídeo no olvides darle al
botón de like i suscribiros adiós al
político hasta la última de todo lo
nuevo por cierto si vives en una cueva y
todavía no te has enterado y hemos
sacado un nuevo canal de youtube se
llama megaproyectos con catherine al
político
os dejo por aquí el enlace para que
también le echéis un vistazo una vez más
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima